welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by both tim
davey
and tim kay's mage who are both the
founding directors of infra view in for
you are a specialist cloud and iit
infrastructure technology recruitment
business they both founded the company
in 2016
after both working for scotland may and
in which they both climbed the ranks to
direct level before deciding to set up
on their own for the last five years
they've been completely dedicated to
building the number one recruitment
brand within their markets they
currently have nine people in the
business but due to continued success
over the last 12 18 months that big
plans to grow the business even further
over the next five
chaps it's a pleasure to have you on the
pod
lovely to be here yeah thanks for uh
thanks for the invite
so obviously both of you called tim so
we've sort of agreed that
uh cause i'm gonna call you kaz yeah tim
dave and i call you tim right just so
everyone knows who i'm speaking so where
we like to start on this podcast is is
ultimately the million pound question
and and that question is casual i'm
gonna come to you first on this to get
your thoughts so the question is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
uh yeah
first of all thanks for coming to me
first uh no pressure there um yeah well
no i i think for me really over the
years i can just go on my own experience
you know i think hard work and passion
um you know love your niche always be
learning remain teachable and uh you
know someone that's extremely hard
working you know i think there's this
myth out there that you can make a
million pounds in your first year in
recruitment and it's just not true you
know i think you know you've got to
absolutely put the work in put the hours
in um and uh yeah
be extremely passionate about the market
that you choose to do and live and
breathe it
yeah i love that i love um love your
niche i think that's great tim what
about you what would you add what what
comes up for you if you think of your
journey the people you work with that
have been really great
what comes up for you
i mean it's all the cheesy buzzwords
isn't it
motivation determination but for me it's
consistency you know if you're gonna do
something make sure you do it
consistency consistently whether it's
marketing whether it's linkedin whether
it's bd whether it's resourcing you know
find a process stick to it and be there
do it consistently and uh don't cut
corners love that so look here so
obviously we're going to spend quite a
bit of time in this episode talking
about
the the business journey so far but i
just want to um just spend the first
couple of minutes just touching on both
of your careers as actual employees
because you both built out successful
recruitment careers before you started
the interview journey
so i guess tim let me come to you first
really i guess what what people would be
interested in obviously you work for
brands like s3
then obviously went stock in may so i
guess um
for you for you tim then i'll come to
you kaz like
what what were some of the
sort of early things in your career that
really helped you excel your recruitment
career do you think like what did you
have to learn the hard way or maybe what
advice did you receive early on that
helped you move on your career a lot of
people listen to this have aspirations
to be top builders start their own
companies like if we were to think about
the early days
um and the years before interview what
were some of the things that really
helped you excel do you think and
progress your career
yeah i mean that's that's that's a great
question i really think think back to my
that's a long time ago 17 years ago my
first year
and what i did and um
i joined a company with about
about 15 people there was a leaderboard
on the wall i wanted to be top
leaderboard so i went and sat next to
the top five people on the leaderboard
and you know asked them how they did it
looked at how they did it
took ideas off the the top five people
in the room i tried to mix all of what
they did throw in my own style to it and
then work harder than them yeah i'm off
one by one so i mean i think the first
year it's the hottest year improvement
isn't it because you know once you know
what you're doing it's it's like boiling
a kettle isn't it once the kettle is
boiling it doesn't take a lot of energy
to keep it boiling yeah i'm not taking a
cold kettle from ice cold to boiling
that takes a lot of energy and a lot of
a lot of effort i know i sort of relate
that to the first year improvement you
know you've got to do a lot more
activity in the first year you've got to
you know understand your market build
your your network um you know work
harder than the person next to you to
get ahead of them so for me it was hard
work i was coming in weekends i was
working evenings i i was doing whatever
everyone else was doing but doing twice
as much of it so you know working
double smart but double hard as well
yeah um eventually you know overcoming
and rising up that leads more than
getting to the top so for me it's i mean
the first year is just you know working
smart but working hard as well
you know if you like twice as hard as
someone else
tim davey who works like tim davey and
then tim davey who works twice as hard
the the guy that works for us
twice as much
yeah all right so where can i as well
yeah so um
caz let me change the question slightly
yeah so
so basically i guess what what obviously
people interested in are those sort of
like maybe and you may you may go you
know what he should actually i didn't
really experience these things it was
just consistency hard work showing up
every day but people interested in like
those sort of breakthrough moments or
those like
aha moments or whatever and a lot of
people listen to this will have
aspirations to get to that a.d position
get a direct within their company and
obviously you achieved that at start in
may right um and as we're just talking
obviously if you've got people sat next
to you like tim davey who is going to
work double hard as you your competitive
intern as well as you are externally in
in your markets right so i guess
were there any moments for you guys
where you felt like maybe things clicked
and you changed a certain way maybe your
mindset change and shifted that you felt
really propelled you to get to that a d
position and then the position you got
to before you started interview
yeah sure god i mean look for me um
i don't this is a good or bad thing
nothing was ever enough for me if i'm
honest and today i still suffer from
that i always want more right in in work
outside of work in relationships with my
kids i want everyone to be you know i
always want to have more and when i
first got into recruitment i quickly
just fell in love with it i just sort of
looked at you know an opportunity to
make money double quick and you know i
was taught at an early age that back to
basics is key you know be as thorough as
you possibly can be process driven but
have that hunger that passion that
desire to make it happen so it was kind
of like um i come from quite an
aggressive sporting background um and it
was kind of like i sort of put that sort
of positivity
but aggression and hard work into
recruitment you know um if i'm honest i
come from a landscape gardening
background when i first got into
recruitment and i was like i didn't know
anything about it i've never walked into
an office i never won a suit but i kind
of very quickly thought well you know
instead of finding two cvs let's find
four instead of working two jobs it's
worth four jobs right and i was always
constantly just trying to push myself
and just work that a little bit harder
but what was ingrained in me from an
early age my first ever boss he was like
don't cut corners be process driven you
know and and this is what we've sort of
implemented throughout teams that myself
and tim have grown over the years it's
like you know
yes you can have all the passion desire
and and will to be successful but if you
cut corners if you're not thorough if
you're not process driven um you know
things are going to fall short at some
point of that process throughout
recruitment right recruitment is not
difficult okay but people make it really
complicated because they try and get to
that end goal too quick and they miss
what needs to be put into place from day
one so look i mean i go back to old
school profiling pre-screening i mean i
had to sit there and profile you know 50
cvs a day you know i had to stand in an
open floor sort of four weeks into
recruiting and sell that to my boss
which was pretty intimidating but it
taught me from an early age don't miss
anything you know yeah so so yeah for me
it's totally driven yeah absolutely you
know back to basics don't get corners be
process driven
because like tim said earlier you can
have all the cheesy buzzwords the hunger
the passion desire the drive yeah and
look if you you know you need that in
any sales job but you know compliment
that with someone that's process driven
you know this thorough you know that you
know doesn't want to leave anything
unturned then uh yeah that's a perfect
blend yeah
okay so kaz let me come back to you
something quick and i guess you may say
the same things but basically
i think i said she before so i dropped
one of your old colleagues a message
ollie
who basically and he uh he he was just
really interested
to find out
like the question really was like what's
tim's journey sort of been from his
mindset of going from like being a
massive biller which is what he knew you
as to then maybe changing your mindset
and style because then you had to go
into more of a leadership role and then
now obviously going into being a
business owner and obviously the mindset
that takes yep and so i guess what i was
trying to focus on is the as you being
like a really high performing villa
right i guess what i just want you to
share with us is i'm sure you have
plenty of people starting maybe now an
interview who they'll sit down with you
and go uh tim i want to be
as i want to be building what you're
building i want to i want to pick you to
the top top builder post right what
prevents
them from achieving that do you think
what are the typical stumbling blocks
that means that they don't achieve that
so it sounds like there's a couple of
questions there so
uh what
what stops my stuff from being potential
is because at the first yeah so it
sounded like you were asking me um you
know what was the change in the mindset
transition yeah so we'll get we'll we'll
park that
we'll go into that okay i wanted to
focus on the you being a high performer
which he was known as okay yeah and i
guess i just wanted to talk a bit more
about so you're saying process is
important not cutting corners all of
this yeah so i guess i just wanted you
to share what comes up for you when we
think about
when people say i want to be where you
are kaz yep and then you see them go
through certain stumbling blocks or
common things that come up that prevent
them from achieving that or them
maximizing their potential i don't know
if there's anything that comes up for
you yeah no absolutely i mean it's
similar to what we just sort of
discussed in terms of you know make sure
you you know you cover the basics you're
process driven utilize all the tools
that are around you to be successful
whether that be technology or whether
that be like tim mentioned earlier well
who's the best in your business right
now who's earning the most amount of
money who's the most successful well
yeah go and speak to them pick their
brains copy them and then uh you know
put your own spin on it add your own
personality and character and make and
and be better right yeah and i got it so
nothing was ever enough for me so you
know i'm hoping that you know when um
you know our staff look at top billers
you know what they should be doing and
what we advise them to do is go and sit
with them you know go and be mentored by
them um you know i i'm a big believer if
you can always always remain teachable
right i don't care if you've had one
year recruitment or 20 years recruitment
you know there is always something you
can be learning from someone that has
less or more experience than you so if
there's something there that you know um
that that you believe that can add
value to you know your process or your
billings or your experience and get you
to that point where you want to be an
a.d then yeah why would you not go to
someone who's already been on that
journey and prove success doing it right
um yeah some people don't want to be an
ad though right some people just want to
be a monster villa great um you know
other people that want to go down the
track of being a leader building a
practice growing a division and then
getting to ads so you know i think i i
think it's about asking questions um you
know being surrounded by the right
people being in a business that can
support
um you know your journey and your your
past because you know one hat doesn't
fit all as we all know now in
recruitment it's not like you know
coming in do delivery for three months
ago 360. that's not what equipment's all
about now it's about utilizing your
strengths where you can be most
passionate about you know hopefully
making the most amount of money but
enjoying it while you develop and
progress
yeah no i i really love the remain
teachable and the fact that how long
you've been in it and that's still you
see that i've been i just i just i think
that's where sometimes people can fall
short they don't remain teachable
and so okay tim what about you what
comes up for you obviously i'm sure
you've been around
high performers people telling me that
they want to be the top builder you've
been in leadership positions like
any other stumbling blocks that come up
for you that you think
prevent people from achieving what they
set out to or doesn't stops them from
becoming what they could be
yeah i mean it's the cut in the corners
and consistency thing again but
if if that actual internal deep rooted
motivation isn't there
are people being true to themselves and
real to themselves about actually is
that what they want you know it's like
you speak to high performing sports
people you know they've had to make
sacrifices you know to this guy
yesterday um
multi
you know he wasn't going out and seeing
his friends he was making priority life
choices i mean not being as dramatic as
recruitment's like winning a gold medal
in the olympics but you know certainly
if someone's saying i think but mentally
hasn't made that commitment to making
that happen because there are sacrifices
you have to make i mean you know if it
was that straightforward everyone would
be joining ferraris and earning millions
of pounds a year but it is commitment um
being consistent turning up every day
not cutting corners and and and being
true to yourself that you actually do
want what what you're committed to doing
and then backing that up with you know
that commitment and consistency okay
so
final question around this and then
we'll go into like the business journey
just interest this is probably one of
the most common questions that i get in
my inbox
um from recruiters so it's because i'll
come i'll come back to you
i'm assuming here but you strike me as
someone that might be
a quite disciplined person yep and and
the most common question i get in my
inbox is like
hisham please can you ask high
performing billers what their typical
day plan looked like when they was at
the top of the leaderboard smashing
targets compared to maybe what it looked
like earlier on when they're trying to
learn the ropes making more mistakes
i don't know and if in there like how
did you stretch your day for success
basically that's what people want to
know yep so so i can i can answer that
really simply so i still have a day plan
now as an owner love it okay yeah okay
so i have a to-do list and i have a to-b
list right so to-do list
absolutely yeah yeah i've got a to-do
list is uh um you know will be done
before i leave that evening so when i
come in and yeah um oh god i won't boy
the details but i'm that annoying person
i guess about half five every single day
i know i want the details people people
like this [ __ ] yeah yeah so let's break
down a normal day then let's do it cool
so i get up at r5 every single day
without you know without without any
rumble yeah i get up i pray i do prayer
meditation i get myself in the zone um i
have breakfast i get down the gym i
smash the life out of it for an hour and
a half and my thinking around that is
i've started before most other people
yeah so i've achieved something before
most other people already you've won the
day you've won the day i'm ahead of
everyone right yeah i want to come first
yeah so whether you're a biller a
manager team leader or an owner okay i
need to know that i am far more prepared
and in front of everyone else okay yeah
so you know i've already achieved
something before i even steps in this
office i've got my to-do list yeah
straight away yeah and that day planner
hasn't changed from when i first got
shown it printed it out and had to fill
in myself what i want to do yeah from
quarter to nine to quarter to twelve
then i'll have my break and then before
i start again after my lunch break what
i want to do from quarter two to quarter
to five and then what am i gonna do from
half five till seven o'clock okay so
yeah that hasn't changed it's just got
different activities now because i'm in
a different role okay so i'm still
regiment yeah i'm still disciplined yeah
i am i've got my to-do list my to-be
list is you know who i want to be how i
want to be perceived how i want to be as
an individual how i want to be as a
leader i want to be as a manager you
know i don't want to be full so you
write it down in the morning or you
think about it or absol absolutely yeah
you know and i work on that and if i
fail at that i look at where i've failed
and i look at how i want to achieve and
become better at that because you know i
think a lot of people you know it's it's
all very easy to put a to-do list
together the hard part is to stick here
right it's like anything tim mentioned
the sport and analogy earlier but you
know what's the hardest part about going
for a run i ask you that question what's
the hardest part about going for a run
making doing it how are you doing the
run putting your shoes on right now
yeah putting your trainers on you know
once you get going you've committed so
you've got to kind of do it yeah you're
either going to do it you're either
gonna do it really fast or do it really
slow but you're doing it so that's done
yeah yeah for me the successful part is
putting the actual trainers on that's
where the success comes once you've got
to the end goal i you've tipped that
line and you've beaten your record or
whatever that's just the achievement
okay but you know for me you know
nothing changes i am disciplined i am
regiment but you know um i can be 100
miles per hour and i'm a bit crazy and a
bit mad but you know i've got to
discipline that in a certain way so you
know like i said you know my plan hasn't
changed my activities do as you know you
would expect going from a super biller
to them being a leader director to them
being a founder yeah um
but but yeah i mean that's probably a
long time
no no no it's great i love the i love
the to be fit i love the to be part i
think that's awesome i think that's such
a i think it's important you know what
you know what what owners or founders or
you know leaders out there are actually
looking at themselves every single day
and going you know who do i want to be
yeah how do i want to be perceived and
seen i don't want to be anyone in my
office that when any of my staff yeah
meet me outside whether it be a social
event or on a weekend yeah i don't want
to be exactly the same person i would be
approachable you know i want to be
someone that they can come over to me
and ask me and talk to me about anything
you know that's how i live and breathe
my life today i want people to actually
generally come up to me and be able to
you know ask me whether it be work or
non-work related um i think something i
think i feel like i'm assuming here but
obviously that help that shows up then
in your decision making right if you've
got a clear idea of who kaz wants to be
your decision-making is going to be a
bit easier because you can come back to
these values or whatever you want to
call them and what yeah and what your
decisions are i think you can own what
you know that you're good at and what
you're not right i mean you know you
know when me and tim you know we both
have the same sort of aspirations you
know to take in for view to be the
number one sort of cloud night
infrastructure technology recruitment
company in the uk but we're too
completely different sort of
personalities and characters we still
got the same burning desire and passion
to be the best but you know we are
completely different so we've got to
utilize each other's strengths and
weaknesses and you know lean and work on
each other and that was probably the
hardest part and that's probably a
question you've got for us later on yeah
yeah yeah
i won't ruin that
okay so and then just find a point on
this because i think it's the do you
plan your to-do list the day before
like i said yeah my to-do list is done
before i walk out that evening yeah
absolutely yeah perfect i just want
people to remember that because i think
yeah if people just start doing that one
thing they can start building great
habits i think listen and and that is if
you you know first day in recruitment or
you know if you're a super biller right
you yeah if you stay average and like
tim said if you're not if you then
become unconsistent and unregiment and
undisciplined there's only one way and
that's backwards right yeah if you're
going to continue you want to you know
be better you know and and go from
ability to a super villa to a monster
villa right if you don't have that to-do
list and it's not set out and planned
you know you're setting yourself up for
a fall you know how often do we see
recruit you know consultants come in
here you know it's five to nine meetings
at nine o'clock they haven't had their
breakfast coffee they don't know what
they're doing you know we have a team me
and what you working today are not too
short you know what we're not here to
put a kpi driven sort of you know um
horrible environment but look come on we
want people to take accountability for
their own actions and you know take
responsible for their billings and it
starts i believe before they walk out
that door so they know exactly what
they're coming into the next day
yeah i love that
tim
how
let's go into this business journey then
but as as we go interested like how did
you guys meet tell me about how you guys
meet how'd that happen
i'll let you start david
the full story
about 21 years ago i i was going out
with a girl and her best friend
her boyfriend was typing
friends with best mates oh wow
that's actually how you first met okay
eight years of not being in touch really
but um
talking a little bit on linkedin that
tim was in recruitment so obviously then
you know we got on in the in the years
gone by followed him as a recruiter when
i was at start of may and we're sort of
in the founding days of fights with
people looking to grow i noticed tim
changed his things in profile as as if
he was sort of teeing himself up for a
new opportunity to reach out at that
time and then uh yeah the rest is
written in the stars really love that so
cool so tim like always like to um start
here but like what what gave you
the confidence to take that step because
a lot of people will talk about we'll be
down the pub
looking at their pay slip going i'll
build 400 grand this year i got paid
this much i'm doing it on my own but
never actually do it right i'm sure
you've met loads of people like that so
what gave you the confidence tim do you
think you personally to start this
journey take that first step
belief in your own ability just you know
maybe a slight bit of arrogance but you
know deep confidence that you know you
you can do this whether you're working
for someone else for yourself and for me
i've done the same market since 2004. so
you know
and then i went to stockholm and
there was no there was no company when i
started scotland so i built the
infrastructure practice there so i'd
already done it uh
um and i was like well i've done it for
scotland i've done it before
there's no
practices and managed to black even so i
built that practice twice previously so
that was an absolute no-brainer yeah
my ability to absolutely make it happen
no matter what was thrown at me um that
it was going to work and
um you know we hadn't decided that tim
was going to join me when tim came six
months later but um you know it was
always a an absolutely no brainer that
together we're going to be a force to be
reckoned with in this space okay love it
so
just to like paint a picture for people
and then kaz i'm gonna answer that
question that you mentioned
so obviously you're at where you're at
now also there's nine of you and i know
both of you are really keen because of
the journey that you've both been on in
like the last 12 18 months you've you've
done a lot of hard work to make sure
like when you're bringing people in now
you've got the infrastructure you've got
the processes to grow this business so
just quickly to paint a picture so as
you just said there kaz joined you six
months after you started tim
so yeah so is it fair to say then what
for the first what two
three years was it like a small group of
you just sort of smashing in there was
like is that is that what the business
looked like in the first two years
pretty much the first two and a half
years was first six months me in a room
doing recruitment okay
tim joined me me and tim and doing
recruitment
um in fact our office was smaller than
this meeting room that i'm sitting in at
the moment you know the the door to the
room sort of scraped off the desk once i
looked in
so yeah that was the description two and
a half years um then we started building
out some sort of delivery capability
around us
uh and then at the start of um 2020 we
moved into this office here in serbian
yeah which fits 19 people and took a
decision to scale up yeah i love it yeah
and that's what i'm really keen to go so
thanks for painting that so i guess what
i'm interested in i think probably
people can engage it like when i hear
tim speak he's got a different energy
about him kaz when you speak 100 miles
our passion energy like i'm i think
obviously a lot of founders i speak to
the solo founders definitely say when i
ask them
what would you maybe do differently
they'd say i think it would have been
great to start this journey with someone
or have someone involved right so
there's both of you after six months in
tim you obviously really bought into
cows his ability and and what he could
add to the business
so i guess to you then like
how what's been the journey on both of
you guys remaining aligned then unlike
what you wanted to achieve right so
we're just saying two and a half years
like you've been on your own sort of
journey but since 2020 it's been a bit
of a different journey so talk to me
about your experience of that like how
did you make sure you and tim were going
in the right direct same direction yeah
i mean it's a good question and that
we're always uh you know
what's i mean the first thing for me
here is is is clear communication right
clear line of communication between us
both i mean like you know like tim said
we've known each other the years we've
always got on but it's always been going
out there having a bit of a laugh we've
never actually yeah you know we worked
together at stotton may we built a
practices together you know we were both
very successful but we were against each
other let's have it right yeah you know
let's be totally honest you know he
wanted to be top biller i want to be top
biller one year i won he won vice versa
etc so it's very different when suddenly
you put two sort of strong-minded
passionate yeah top billers um that have
always pretty much done it their own way
yeah yeah and and it's always worked and
then suddenly put them in a room then
it's like right we're now working
together who's making that decision yeah
who's getting that overall say of you
know uh you know what we're actually
ordering what we're doing how we're
growing at what pace and stuff like that
so for me personally you know that was a
bit of a challenge right for the first
year you know for the first couple years
it's two guys sitting in a room doing
exactly what they've done for many many
years you know doing recruitment getting
cash rich quick but then when business
decisions comes into play you kind of
got to work out very quickly
you know who's doing what yeah so i kind
of sort of fall into the sales
directorship role tim davey falls into
the operational director role but we
both do sales we both win business we
both make money but it's kind of like i
think personally for the first when we
realized that we wanted to grow and
scale up and you know we moved into this
new office it was kind of like what i
think the big thing for any owners or
any business starting out when you've
got two different personalities work out
who wants to do what you know what are
your roles define them because if you
don't there's you are clashing not
necessarily in a negative way but you
find yourself sort of
laughing maybe yeah yeah overlapping
right and you find two people doing one
job when actually one person could be
doing it better right yeah yeah um yeah
and and that and and that for us has
been huge over the last 18 months since
we sort of you know clearly defined what
davey does what kaz does yeah yeah what
does david want to do moving forward
what does caz want to do yeah you know
because together you know we're together
great we get on that's brilliant you
know you know we're good mates you know
we're both good at what we do but you
know that doesn't scale a business right
we've got to make decisions that allows
us to um yeah be interesting to the
outsiders looking in and if we don't
know what we do how can we put that
across to people when they come in and
go well where do you guys want to go
does that make sense yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think what what i take from that as
well which i think is really important
is that when you've defined those roles
or what you want to do and what you are
doing all of a sudden then like you can
very you can both hold each other
accountable and you know what you're
accountable for and i think that that
instead of both of you being accountable
both of you being responsible for that
you can go well i'm this why i'm in
charge of i'm going to deliver this and
then it's that accountability pieces in
there on certain aspects absolutely yeah
definitely and you're both you know you
both usually have got to utilize each
other's strengths um you know if
identifying where one person you know
for instance i don't there's certain
things i just don't want to do could i
do it davey's just far better and
there's other things that he doesn't
want to do could he do it yes but you
know why put someone through something
that they don't want to do if someone
else can do it far better and he's going
to enjoy it right you're just going to
get a better result um and it allows you
to you know free up time to actually
execute the stuff you're really good at
and do it to your best ability right so
that for us has been massive you know
since we've realized exactly how we
defined those roles
love that so
tim let's talk about 2020 then so
obviously
you've got this office space that you're
now in which i've seen online and stuff
which looks great
like just talk to me about from your
perspective
i'm really excited to go into like maybe
some of the key things that you've both
made decisions on that you've
implemented that you've invested time in
that have really set you up to scale up
but what tim what changed for you
personally or you could talk for both
people anything change mentally but what
what sparked the light you know what
let's give this a real go in terms of
growing this out of interest
yeah started before 2020 um
with the plan to get into the office to
to actually analyze and make a plan for
what we wanted him for to look like
moving forward so um started 2020 we
moved into the office and the plan was
always
to fill out this office and to grow um
whilst whilst kobe gave us a slight
hiccup but we we still thrive through
through covid um
it did give us a bit of time i suppose
lockdowns and things like that gave us
the time to look at
putting some processes into place to
scale up so okay outsourcing on
marketing outsourcing our finance and uh
and going to um you know discount
factory as opposed to
uh using solid 8 um
moving to vincerie and integrating crms
and internal processes um putting
together an onboarding and development
program that tim's put together um and
there's sort of the extra time that i
suppose lockdowns maybe afforded us to
put in um
yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so let's break let's
break this down a bit if it's okay tim
and then cause you can jump in when you
want to but i get because i think this
is gonna
this is this is um this is what i didn't
see like one of the most common
questions i get so i know you guys are
at nine right but i think obviously we
can all agree you've really done the
hard yards to make sure like when you're
at 20 people 15 people 19 people like
what you've done the hard yards on is
going to enable you to for this business
to be successful when you've got those
people so a lot of people ask me
hisham there's ten of us there's five of
us and like what what advice can you get
from people to help me go from five to
fifteen to twenty et cetera
so let's just break this down a bit tim
because you said a few things there
right so i guess first question i have
to uncover some of the key areas so
what would you say you've been the most
important areas that you've invested
time resources money into the you feel
has given both of you confidence to go
you know what if we do have get another
10 people in here over the next 12
months we're going to be good and
they're going to be self successful
yeah um kind of all of them i know
that's the easy question but um but our
internal processes as well and we still
haven't finished that journey so at the
moment we're looking to our first back
office internal person um so we're
looking for an ops manager um to pull
together all of those processes get into
mine and tim's mind take everything out
of there and put it into an operational
you know structured process but um i
mean marketing is a big one for us both
both me and tim are really keen
perception out of the market is as
strong as you know the perception that
people have who've engaged with us so we
um behind a marketing uh guy jake
internally uh he's been fantastic and
then alongside outsourcing uh alongside
of that to our digital agency and uh
another marketing partner so marketing
so mike so martin has been a lot you've
been invested in
well
um
crm so we we were we were on a crm that
wasn't really fit for our needs so you
know analyzed the market and
yeah chose uh chosen cherry which has
been fantastic for us so um so that's
been great pulling together again the
internal processes um and then moving
away as we've grown out our contract
offering um going away to an outsourced
finance provider that
manages um you know paying a bill on
contractors um timesheets um taking that
all the way from from from us having to
do it um as well as all the payroll and
back office and all that kind of stuff
so um yeah three three separate things
there in internal crm that is that the
heart of everything that goes on from a
sales perspective marketing for external
and uh and finance for obvious reasons
okay and then what i'm interested in so
i writing and sending you so cuz you've
spent time on development like is that
like for a consult like someone that
joined your business what their journey
looks like in front of you is that right
yeah absolutely things that you did yeah
you know i think what's important is uh
um anyone coming into any business at
any level needs to know that you know
where can they go what's the what's the
path look like how can they develop what
training do they get you know who they
can be surrounded by um you know make
sure there's no ceiling right and like
tim said as a business um you know
through covid we looked at our business
inwards supposed to outwards outwards we
were great loads of clients loads of
business really successful catch rich
inwards it was like okay well we're
probably wearing too many hats we're
doing a bit marketing bit of branding
you know we're doing the finance
ourselves it was like right let's just
outsource the areas that are bogging us
down um allow us to look at um
uh you know our company in terms of you
know where are necessarily the failures
but what need more enhancement and
development right and uh you know we
need to put an on-boarding structure
training development plan which we've
done now for trainees what we've done
for consultants what we've done for
leadership and management okay so you
know um it's been brilliant you know um
it's it's early days and far from the
finish article but um you know we are
still a nine-man business or a nine-man
and women business um but uh you know
it's it's been really successful uh
we've had three new starters uh over the
last six weeks uh feedback's been really
positive in terms of the onboarding and
the initial sort of training and
development but i think what's really
clear
what key for us is
to have that clear
concise message yeah from the top so
everyone knows exactly you know what our
business is what we specialize in where
we want to go and what the strategy is
to do that and let's face it you know if
you're hiring people in whether it be a
trainee or a senior consultant they are
part of making that strategy work
they're part of going on that journey
with us so if they don't see it
buy it and they're committed to it
um
it's not going to be it's not going to
work yeah
we're all about that bringing people in
together and making decisions
collaboratively to you know to to buy
into that
no i love that so it's a just just quick
one yeah so
as we were saying before we started
right i think a lot of agencies right
now
um see the opportunity that they have to
place the jobs that they have like
they've got jobs coming out their ears
and really
there's a lot more trainees coming into
the market right and one of the most
common things that i hear from young
professionals as to like what one of
their main drivers is or motivations is
is progression
like yes the good earning potential
incentives all of that but as you just
said if i can join the interview sit
down with you and you go right this is
where we are today this is where we're
going and this is the part you can play
and if you do these things this is where
you can go
so i think this is where sometimes i
think a lot of smaller growing agencies
fall short because they may think oh
we'll think about a career plan or
whether when we're 15 people 20 people
right so can i just ask you you don't
have to go for like day by day but
what did your
like i guess what did it look like
before
a rough art picture of like what did it
look like if i joined interview what did
it maybe look like in terms of my own
boarding what my career progression that
um the structure looked like
and then two
like what what does it sort of now look
like again don't have to go into like
day by day but like what is it now that
if i join how long is he on board in how
have you mapped out the career journey
have you got like a sort of leadership
path with what people have done have you
just got like a billing path i think
that would be really helpful for people
yeah got it god i can go i could
probably talk for an hour about that but
um look what you'll get to know about me
is i'm really transparent and honest
right so two when we first started two
years ago we didn't have any onboarding
it's the truth right he didn't have he
didn't have an on board
just being honest right you know and we
hired people that we knew that we worked
with in the past that we trusted and
liked and knew that we'll be able to
come in slot into our market into our
business and make money right so yeah we
kind of sort of by default didn't have
to worry about the sort of ongoing
training program because we knew these
people and you know they were trusted
and liked to us so yeah first couple
years we're just yeah just doing what
we've always done for multiple
businesses right so like i said earlier
when we actually looked at our business
inwards and how we want to be seen from
the outside of looking in and how can we
make our business repeatable and
scalable you know and appealing to all
levels yeah whether it be a trainee or a
senior recruitment consultant we've now
put that in place so i think it starts
from the very beginning the moment they
go through that door you know for us
both tim and i and you know the current
leaders within our business we want to
make sure that that is cemented the
moment they walk through that door that
they have made the right decision yeah
so we have an interview process which is
two three stages sometimes longer you
know and then suddenly they've got
notice to serve you know and let's face
it they could be sitting there you know
worried thinking have they made the
right decision have they not or just
super excited about walking through so
that level of excitement needs to be
absolutely maintained the moment they
step through so their journey starts
yeah that induction so god i won't go
step by step but once you've done all
the housekeeping right you know for us
we do a big presentation yeah around uh
um you know
our why how we do it what we do our
journey our team our division our
clients the future you know and and and
how he or she will play a part in that
you know and that's not just a stand-up
let's chat for five minutes you know
that's a two-hour presentation on almost
like i said cementing why
they accepted it and are excited about
joining us and uh um you know
we could go and you know all the bits
about profiling pre-screening candidates
you know how to map and build a market
in a division all of that is implemented
and it's all sectioned it's all
categorized but instead of stick we're
not old school sort of large aggressive
recruitment um i don't want to name
names but it's kind of like we don't
stick people in the meeting room for two
weeks and then go right go here's a post
code this is a skill set yeah no exactly
you know it's it's ongoing development
and training um and you know generally
they will start doing delivery off the
back of our existing customers and
positions that we have but we will then
with them carve out a path that is
either going down a super billa route or
a team lead or a building a practice
which involves um still staying within
our core cloud90 infrastructure yeah
building a market out of what we've
already got in place to then you know
hopefully go on to be you know a.d
director and then head of head of
contract yeah yeah so you've mapped all
that out the different routes yeah it is
all you know
yeah
everything is you know the roles the
roles and duties and responsibilities um
you know each step of the way is mapped
out but the onboarding training
development is a separate mapping yeah
yeah so they can visually see the moment
they walk through this door you know
what they're involved with and it
doesn't involve like i said sitting in a
classroom watching a video or talking to
a non-villain that doesn't know how to
recruit and then in two weeks time given
the postcode go for the database pick a
client up sound really rubbish you know
we want to nurture
who we hire yeah and make them sound
knowledgeable credible become a
specialist in our niche yeah so when
they do go out and start attacking the
market and start building out a network
whether it be candidate client or both
they sound credible knowledgeable and
you know what and get excited about it
you know be excited we want you know we
want people to be excited about coming
into interview and becoming a specialist
in our market you know we live and
breathe it daily so you know we'll do
everything in our power to get them to
that point and if it's not structured
and it's not mapped out and we aren't
all committed together and we can
visually see that how can we possibly
you know uh get the best results
yeah i love that thanks
but yeah we've matched that to two
different routes whether it's the
recruitment consultant with sales bd
without sales both for justice valuable
uh nowadays i mean back in the day you
know just throw 360's at it right yeah
yeah
but you know we have the we have the
sort of last minute of what you what you
call the 270 uh model and the 360 model
and the 180 model running in tangent uh
and then there's the super billion route
or there's the
billing team leader and growing a team
group so yeah we have both documented
and structured and you know each step of
that journey uh documented on the uh
on the interview team site open for
everyone to see and uh and
the goals to attain to this step up on
all of those journeys
i think that'd be really helpful for
people so tim
obviously what why be keen to get your
thoughts and then casfield to um add to
it as well so obviously that journey
then that you were just talking about
it's safe to say that there's a lot of
first in there right doing things for
the first time mapping these types of
things out obviously tim i've always
seen you at a little networking event
mate yeah i love showing over there so
the the question i have for you because
it's a really common one i get from
agency leaders
is like what have you have you ever gone
down the path of getting help if that's
maybe an nd or getting advice or
whatever like obviously these things
that you might obviously look to get
help with like what's what's been your
journey with that because a lot of
people ask me he should be great if you
could ask agents showing us like how
they've gone about getting a good ned or
how do they do that and these things
like did you go down that path at all
yeah i mean we were mentioning names and
networks and things
yeah well you you tell me whatever you
want to share that that's that's helped
you that that's that's what people get
people interested in yeah
we
we're great recruiters and we're great
leaders but you know we've we're running
a business for the first time whilst
we've run businesses within businesses
yeah and we're not so afraid to think
that we know everything about everything
so yeah we definitely reach out for help
when when required um you know we've
learned on a few different people we've
we've met some
some individuals but um i mean probably
worth mentioning the recruitment network
james bond gordon i mean we've been
members of them for a long time to
really lean on them you know regularly
for you know advice and then the rest of
the network i mean like you say
networking events yeah business owners
business leaders so you know there's
there's a few that we liaise with on a
regular basis and you know we go to for
support and we're happy to share as well
so you know
it's not collaborative it's not like one
way it's not you're just taking it's
give and take
but back in the day it was like you know
there was always that kind of i don't
want to see any other recruiter i don't
want the recruiters to know what i'm
doing and you know that was so you know
15 10 15 years ago but um yeah sharing
what we do with it with others and and
learning from others along the way so
you know there's a few businesses that
we really rate and you know
not try and copy but you know learn from
what they're doing well and then put the
interview stamp on it um you know then
we're members of members only and uh
wide as well um
yes
we met you at you know industry events
and all that kind of stuff so um
quite organic then
yeah i mean it's just it's just
developed over time so i mean you know
we
and we're friendly guys so you know we
network quite well um in the industry
hopefully now so you know if we don't
know something we're you know we are
quick to you know go out and lean on a
network and find that out but yeah
recruitment network james osborne
important so i've been you know
fantastically in the last year
the doing recruitment in a room with
other recruiters is helping us
facilitate further that that's easy but
getting into
we've absolutely utilized you know uh
additional strengths around us why
wouldn't we yeah you know like we said
earlier when you ask the question what
advice would we give to a uh to to an
up-and-coming consultant that want to be
a super builder we'll go to you know the
best consultant in that company and ask
them so you know if we're looking at
other businesses that are slightly
further on that journey you know that
have built a decent professional you
know recommendable business why would we
not go and pick their ideas and uh um
you know lean on other people that have
done it before and done it well you know
for me that's smart yeah and you know
we're gonna put our spin on it you know
we've we've run and built multiple
divisions in various businesses and all
been successful but yeah while we're not
leaning on other areas that you know
perhaps is slightly out of our remit or
we haven't had experience of and uh yeah
see if we can then uh yeah use what's
around us so yeah absolutely um and yeah
for us it's been yeah that's
all big stuff isn't it i mean it's just
finding advice of who who can create
your new terms of business i mean that's
not a massive thing but yeah yeah
you used a few people before and you
know
so that that mindset that kaza just said
has meant that you're in different
places you can get advice different
things so it's just that open mindedness
to
be teachable or yeah be willing to take
advice from other people and then you
can tell that to different parts of your
business i
i mean you know i learned from you know
your podcast as well yeah i love that so
cool so like comments coming to the end
here so a couple of things
i guess just sort of a couple of wrap-up
questions so cows to you then obviously
seems like since 2020 has been quite
pivotal in in your business journey so
if we were to just think about maybe
what like the last year and a bit a year
and a half's life if we think
from kovid to like now
for you personally what's been like one
of the biggest learns that you think
you're going to
take or continue to take with you moving
forward in your business personally
professionally
what are some of the things that you
really i know you're something that
takes tries to take the positives from
things yeah what's been one of the main
things that comes up for you that you
really learned in this journey that
we've been on all on that you're going
to really take with you forever moving
forward professionally or personally
okay so so i've learned loads yeah so
you know
there's no quicker there's no quick
answer to that honestly um you know but
what i will say is what i've learned
what i've challenged myself on is
probably what i want to answer is
i've learned to let go more yeah so i'm
one of those guys that tried to do 101
things all the time myself because i've
always had that mindset of well if i
know it and can do it and i can do it
well i'll just do it but actually what
that started to do was stopping me from
looking at the wider picture the bigger
picture you know where the tim and i
want to go as a company how do we scale
how we grow whether we outsource all the
things we've discussed today but you
know internally from a sales perspective
you know how can i progress and develop
my staff they are key yeah our staff are
key to the success of interviewing me
and tim you know realized after year two
year three we can't grow this business
ourself yeah we need to buy a top talent
in and when we get top talent at any
level we need to nurture build grow and
develop them okay so we need to stop
doing everything ourselves okay even
though you know we still love recruiting
and we still want to be part of it we're
going to bring business in and make
money but actually over the last 12
months since we started to develop more
internally letting go letting these guys
take accountability for their own
actions in terms of whether it be more
candidate care whether it be more um
client exposure you know starting to win
business themselves because you know we
have been very
lucky and we've made that luck
throughout success over the years of
just living and breathing this market 85
of our business is exclusive you know we
work with top leading tier number one
msp solution providers and actually our
business has been very top-heavy
delivery where you know
it's been great but since off the back
of kovid we've now nurtured internally
and given these guys more accountability
and what's come off the back of that is
we have had a complete uplift yeah in
talon and it's been sitting right in
front of us you know guys and girls have
been coming out their shell and taking
more responsibility more accountability
making more money taking more ownership
and you know organically that's
developed them and then we put a plan in
place to take them on that journey and
develop them further so yeah
um in in short but not so short
no that's great let him go i think that
that'd be really common for people yes
absolutely love that man good on you
and putting the right people in the
right places yeah yeah and that's
maturity as a business we didn't need
that for what we needed two years ago
it's very different to what we need now
but ultimately um people's development
and giving them stuff to strive to
that's what we've really nailed in the
last year
i love that so let's write this up then
tim what what are you most excited about
mate like i can sense like the journey
you guys have been on the hard work you
put in what let's finish it there like
what are you excited about what are you
excited about the future of inferior
what does that look like
just everything it feels like we're just
at the beginning as well yeah so yes
um you know we we had uh a bit of a
delays of cobin in terms of growth but i
mean it feels like we are only just
starting now so love that
years one to four was yeah being in a
room doing recruitment you know getting
cash in the bank and making sure we can
work together and that's been a no you
know it's been pretty pretty
straightforward but you know we we kind
of are building in for view from here
forwards this is where it starts this is
the scalable exciting point where we
turn ourselves from a you know really
successful startup into a you know a
really exciting scale-up business so
that's the excitement for me yeah it's
begun with the onboarding of the three
people that we've had in the last six
weeks and it continues to develop from
there so i'm looking forward to this
time next year when we you know say we
don't want to release the lease on this
office and you know we have a leadership
team we all agree that we want to push
on to the next office in the future from
there so that for me is what's exciting
love it kaz what about you mate
how much more there is to do
yeah
you know tim tim said absolutely
perfectly there you know we've only
scratched the surface we've only just
started yeah yeah well great feeling
right five years in and you feel like
you know what we're just [ __ ]
starting let's
absolutely let's do it let's go and it
is the people that we hire right now
that are going to make that difference
to our business and transform it yeah
and you know so i'm going to finish off
saying someone said you want to be a
lifestyle or do you want to be a
scale-up business and we don't want to
be a lifestyle business we could be a
lifestyle business right now and just
sit here and just have a couple of guys
delivering the roles we work pay our
mortgages off and you know god knows how
many years and and that's not what we
want to do you know we're hiring top
talent you know at all levels to come in
and be part of this journey it's going
to be super exciting and uh yeah i just
can't wait to see it just transform into
that next you know number one leading
cloud night infrastructure technology
recruitment company so yeah
what's in space let's do it
tim and tim it's been a pleasure thank
you so much brilliant thanks buddy